wow
number four
thank
oh yeah
so
world
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
well
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hahaha
[Music]
uh
[Music]
ah
wow
[Music]
wow
[Music]
wow
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
be
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
ah
huh
[Music]
so
um
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
do
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
huh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
wow
[Music]
ah
[Music]
time
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
ah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
baby
[Music]
um
[Music]
just reiterating when he hits that light
sails we have to go
okay
straight ahead to the right i'll lead
the charge
there we go
foreign
hi guys
so
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
ah
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
congresswoman cindy axne
[Applause]
well hello how is everybody today
well thank you so much for being here so
so glad to see such a great turnout it's
truly an honor to have the president of
the united states of america here with
us today i'm so thankful that he's here
and it's wonderful to be back here at
poet bioprocessing and to meet with the
people who have been working so hard
folks i've met over the last several
years to produce a renewable domestic
alternative to fossil fuels and folks i
have been fighting tooth and nail for
this year after year
[Applause]
because i always knew that we needed to
make biofuels a part of our clean energy
solution and we're doing that right here
in iowa
investing in biofuels not only helps
iowa's farmers and rural communities but
also lessens our nation's
reliance on fossil fuels and brings down
prices for iowa families
president biden knows that ethanol which
is created right here at poet
bioprocessing
is significantly cheaper at the pump
reduces our carbon emissions and
provides good paying jobs like right
here at poet in menlo and so the
president is here to support that
and so i'm so immensely grateful for the
president's work in upholding the
renewable fuel standard and keeping
biofuel production going strong and i'm
thankful for all the investments
president biden has made in iowa in his
time in office
everyone needs to know how much that is
iowa as we know has more structurally
deficient bridges than any other state
in the nation and thanks to president
biden's leadership we've already
received 650 million dollars in new
funding for roads and bridges
and over the next five years iowa is
expected to receive more than five
billion dollars from the infrastructure
investment act which helped to expand
the des moines airport repair pesky
potholes and make sure that bridges can
bear enough weight so our farmers can
get their goods to market and we're also
getting poisonous lead out of our
drinking water and so much more right
here in iowa and i'm so proud to be a
part of that i'm really proud to have
supported these investments that will
help keep iowa happy and healthy and to
make sure that we right here in iowa
have a fair shot at the 21st century
economy and i'm excited to see the
impact that these investments will have
in our great state
thank you all again so much for coming
out here today and thank you president
biden for your leadership with that
i'm going to turn it over to two
wonderful people
rachel connor who is the green
merchandiser here at poet and joe biden
president of the united states of
america
now
[Music]
it's really great to be here with all of
you today
my name is rachel connor and i am a
grain merchandiser here at the poet
menlo location
what that means is that i help purchase
all the grain in the bins from nearby
farmers
and it's truly the honor of a lifetime
to welcome president joe biden
and all of our distinguished guests to
poet today
i am a fifth generation farmer who was
born and raised right here in iowa
i've spent countless hours on the farm
driving a tractor and many more in
college and grad school studying
agronomy
these days i drive nearly 100 miles
round trip
to work here at poet where we make
plant-based biofuels nutritious feed
and a growing number of renewable
co-products
i'm excited to be part of a company and
an industry that's doing its part to
make the world a better place
since i'll be headed back home about 50
miles tonight you can bet that i'll be
fueling up with e15
[Applause]
and come june 1st i hope to keep saving
money with e15
many of you may recall when president
biden campaigned here in iowa he
promised to support biofuels
grow green jobs and cultivate a
low-carbon economy
today america is battling putin's price
hike
and mr president i can tell you our
nation's entire biofuels industry stands
ready to help
so ladies and gentlemen let's give a
warm iowa welcome to president joe biden
[Applause]
thank you very very much
now as i was campaigning here and i made
that commitment
i don't think anybody heard it but we're
back
we're back and i uh my name is
joe biden i work for
uh congressman axne
there she is
i learned a long time ago when she says
i have a i just say yes
i say yes right off the bat
i tell you what
[Applause]
she is one hell of a champion for you i
mean it i mean you ask anyone if you
ever come to washington
walk into the congress say you know
anybody from iowa the first thing
they'll say they'll mention her name
anyway said thank you thank you for your
friendship to start i'd like to say a
few words about the mass shooting in new
york city subway this morning you've all
read and heard about
jill and i my wife jill and i are
praying for those that are injured and
all those touched by that trauma
we're grateful for all the first
responders who jumped into action
including civilians civilians who didn't
hesitate to help their fellow passengers
and try to shield them
my team has been in touch with mayor
adams and new york's police commissioner
and the department of justice and the
fbi are working closely with the nypd on
the ground we're going to continue to
stay in close contact with new york
authorities and as we learn more about
the situation over the coming hours and
days
and
something could have broken between now
and the last hour i haven't heard the
news i haven't spoken about my staff but
we're not letting up on it till we find
out and we find the the perpetrator
now for the reason i'm here today
i want to thank you rachel and uh thank
you congresswoman axne uh when you hear
about progress you're making in iowa on
everything from biofuels to bridges you
can thank cindy that's what you no i'm
not joking
i am not goku
[Applause]
there's no fence at the white house high
enough to keep her out
not
all kidding aside said you're doing one
heck of a job thank you so much i also
want to say a special hello to someone
who really wanted to be here today and
you think i'm kidding he started he's
the guy that brought me to the first
biofuel plant in iowa years ago
your former governor of my secretary of
agriculture
of
tom
vilsack
couldn't be here today
[Applause]
he went to a press event in washington
and like two-thirds of the people who
went i think they got covert he's doing
fine spoke to him but
he couldn't be here but i'm here today
to talk about the work we're doing to
lower costs for american families and
put rural america at the center of our
efforts to build a future that's made in
america
and that's not hyperbole it's about
being made in america
a lot of that has has to do with this
industry
i just had a chance to see uh the work
you do here and turn more than 40
million bushels of local corn into 130
million gallons of ethanol a year that's
a lot of gallons we want to see
facilities like this all over the
midwest and here's why
first it's support farm it supports
farmers and the farm economy
you know everybody thinks delaware is a
big industrial state and banking state
and dupont
we have a four billion dollar industry
it's called agriculture in delaware and
it's mostly we have more chickens in
delaware broilers chickens than you have
in the entire midwest i think but all
kidding aside it is a big industry in
delaware and my state everybody thinks
is a is an industrial state it's a very
rural state the largest city outside of
the main city of wilmington delaware is
a couple almost 150 000 people is 20 000
people it's a rural state
and uh and so we understand about
getting the rural communities engaged
and being able to make it to be able to
make it generally
and all that corn in the silos is from
farmers within 60 miles of here
knowing you have a buyer gives farmers
something they don't
often have peace of mind
certitude about where their product can
be sold and to get a fair price for it
second it creates good paying jobs it's
estimated there are over 400 000 jobs
directly and indirectly supported by
this industry nationwide there's a lot
of people that's a lot and a lot of
paychecks and good decent paychecks
third it reduces our reliance on foreign
oil by adding this fuel to our gasoline
[Applause]
10 or 15 even more stretches of supply
and fourth
it gives you a choice at the pump
when you have a choice you have
competition when you have competition
you have better prices
in addition to all that you get less
harm to the environment
lower greenhouse gas emissions and you
get even byproducts like grain here
which does goes into animal feed which
helps cattle producers and lowers their
cars
this is an industry with a tremendous
future
i've set a goal of zero carbon for
aviation sector for example by 2050.
i've spoken with the leading
heads of all major airlines it's going
to require billions of gallons of
sustainable aviation fuel you simply
can't get to net zero by 2050 without
biofuels
aviation
[Applause]
aviation isn't the case where you blend
in
a little bit of biofuel it's where it's
called drop in meaning 100 biofuel you
don't need to take my word for it take
the word of the ceo of american airlines
who said sustainable aviation fuel is
the cornerstone of our strategy end of
quote
and the ceo of united airlines who call
the first biofuel powered flight a
significant milestone for our efforts to
decarbonize our industry
to bring that future within reach i
proposed a sustainable aviation fuel tax
that we brought together the
government's agencies aircraft
manufacturers airlines fuel producers
airports advanced cleaner and more
sustainable fuels for american aviation
that's how we're going to get there and
we can
we're in the cusp of so many significant
things are going to happen in this
country not just in the fuel side but in
the next 10 years
your children are going to see more
change in the next 10 years than we've
seen in the last 40 years that's how
rapidly technology is changing so this
industry has a role as play in a
sustainable energy future but i'm here
today because homegrown biofuels have a
role to play right now right now as you
work to get
as you work to get
prices under control and reduce the cost
for families look i grew up in a family
not a joke where if the price of a
gallon of gasoline went up it was a
conversation at our kitchen table it
mattered it mattered with my mom and dad
it made a difference
we felt it
putin's invasion of ukraine has driven
up gas prices and food prices all over
the world
the two largest grand producers in the
world china and uh should be ukraine and
russia
are not doing what they usually do so
everything's going up
we saw today's inflation data
70 percent
of the increase in prices in march came
from putin's price hike in gasoline
we need to address this challenge with
an urgency to the demands
that's why i've called on congress to
move immediately lower the cost of
families utility bills prescription drug
bills and more while lowering the
deficit to reduce inflationary pressures
and that's what we've done we lowered
the depth by 300 billion dollars so far
as expected so folks
we can do these things without raising a
penny in tax on anybody in this in this
hall
in this giant barn
look
it's going to make a big difference for
families
you know it's the most impactful way
that congress can address inflation
right now but even as we work with
congress
i'm not going to wait to take action to
help american families i'm doing
everything within my power by executive
orders to bring down the price and
address the putin price site
in fact we've already made progress
since march inflation data was collected
your family budget your ability to fill
up your tank none of it should hinge on
whether a dictator declares war and
commits genocide a half a world away
to help deal with this putin price hike
i've authorized a release of one million
barrels per day for the next six months
from our strategic petroleum reserve
this is by far the largest release of
our national reserve in history
it's a wartime bridge
to increase oil supply as we work to
with u.s producer oil producers to ramp
up their production this year
coordinated release
with partners and allies around the
world i've spent hours and hours of my
counterparts around the world trying to
get them in and on the deal
and shortly after i made the
announcement over 30 countries
agreed to release another 60 million
additional barrels onto the market over
240 million barrels over the next six
months is the bridge
to be able to make sure we are going to
be able to keep prices down
this is the largest collective reserve
release in history
hundreds of hours of meetings of key
allies keeping them together is paying
off putin
is was counting on the division of nato
the division of the european union's
vision of the world
we've spent a lot of time
but they're all following every single
one including in asia
south korea japan
australia
all of them nations coming together to
help deny putin the ability to weaponize
his energy resources against american
families families in europe and around
the world and by the way we're also
cutting off access to technology for him
without american technology look at the
number of major
american companies on their own
not i'm not at my urge
over 600 of them from exxon to
mcdonald's have left
russia
left russia
he has a burning tundra literally
it's burning
permafrost is burning
he's got a problem and he's cause we're
not gonna let him cause that problem to
spread to the rest of the world
and that helps stop the run-up of oil
prices that have begun to bring prices
down a little bit
as a result countries acting together to
release this reserve and america should
be seeing the savings
and we're not just learning and leaning
on our reserves and our allies and
partners to help bring down the
gas prices and the power of the nation
we're leaning on you
our farmers our biofuel refiners
today
i'm announcing that the environmental
and i don't think as much of
announcement has already broken out
pretty much the last 24 hours but the
environmental protection agency is
planning to issue an emergency waiver
to allow e-15 gasoline that uses more
ethanol from home-grown crops to be sold
across the united states this summer in
order to increase fuel supply
[Applause]
folks
i feel like thank you
i feel like as
as as a minister and i feel like i'm
preaching to the choir here
but here's what it means
the a15 is about 10 cents a gallon
cheaper than e-10
and some gas stations offer an even
bigger discount than that
but many of the gas stations that sell
it here in iowa illinois minnesota
wisconsin pennsylvania are required to
stop selling in the summer
but with this waiver on june 1 you're
not going to show up at your local gas
station
and see a bag over the pump that has the
cheapest gas
you're going to be able to keep filling
up with e15
and it's going to solve a whole problem
it's not going to solve all our problems
but it's going to help some people
and i'm committed to whatever i can to
help
even if it's an extra buck or two in the
pockets that they fill up will make a
difference in people's lives and even
though a15 is only available in a few
thousand pumps today
we're investing more than 100 million
dollars to build biofuel infrastructure
in the future
things like blend pump blender pumps the
gas pumps that can handle higher blends
and bioethanol and diesel fuel
of course
there's more we need to do to bring down
the prices for american families
we're also working to address food
prices
because right now farmers aren't getting
a fair deal
and nationwide
and neither are families at the grocery
store
back in july
i signed an executive order to promote
competition
to help level the playing field for many
family farmers and ranchers
because as many of you here know better
than anyone
that four big companies control more
than half the market for beef pork and
poultry giving ranchers very few choices
about who to sell to to get their
product these big conglomerates drive
down prices they pay farmers and even as
they drive up prices at the grocery
store
so we're investing up to one billion
dollars in american rescue funds for new
and expanded meat and poultry processing
capacity throughout this country
and this is something i've talked about
with brent johnson who is here today
we're going to invest
in innovative new products
and processors
small businesses independent businesses
the lifeblood of our economy
it's going to give farmers and ranchers
more options to shore up a weak point in
our food supply chain and bring down
prices for american families
i've said it before and i say it again
i'm a capitalist but without capitalism
without competition isn't capitalism
it's exploitation
exploitation and bringing down historic
economic progress
reducing costs for families also
requires investing in infrastructure
my introducer's going to drive home 50
miles i got to make sure of the
thousands of bridges in this state and
around the country that aren't safe i
hope you're not going over some of them
and that starts with roads and bridges
it really does
as cindy's pointed out iowa has more
bridges than any other state in the
nation that are classified as
structurally deficient
four thousand
five hundred are in poor condition
and here's the reason why cindy's work
in the infrastructure law was so
important
about two-thirds of the bridges in need
of repair
in this country
are considered off system
because they did not directly on the
interstate highway system
back in january
i was supposed to speak in pittsburgh
which i did
at a steel mill but on the way there
a bridge collapsed in the city
that's what most people don't realize
it's called the city of bridges there's
more bridges in pittsburgh than any
other city in america
and it was and that morning i got there
it collapsed and went straight to the
site
the bridge had been written in poor
condition for the last 10 years
thank god nobody died
it was about i'm guessing
maybe
300 yards across a little bit of a
valley and a shallow creek
and the
steepest part from the bridge to this
creek was probably about
eight or ten stories and it was a snow
day
and that bridge if it weren't a snow day
would have had at the moment it went
down
school buses with hundreds of kids going
across that bridge
this stuff matters
i mean it really matters i was telling
cindy back and i was in small town in
western pennsylvania
and i needed a bridge or the bridge was
only as far as from the length of not
half the length of this this room
and guess what
the fire station was on one side and the
town was on the other
but because they couldn't take the fire
trucks across that bridge because of
afraid it would collapse
they had to go if i'm not mistaken it's
either 10 or 11 miles
five and a half miles up and five and a
half miles back to get there
and they had a fire
and they couldn't get there in time
just because they could see it it was
literally
maybe 500 yards away
they couldn't do anything about it
these bridges are essential
for small towns in my state and yours
towns and rural areas
for farmers to get their products to
market for small businesses to be able
to serve their customers
these are bridges that when they're
closed
shifts off delivery and routes to
schools and fruits home it takes a lot
longer
they create longer delays for first
responders
when every second counts
and you all cindy can cite it for you
the statistics are you get an accident
in a rural area
you have about a 40 percent greater
chance of being dying than you do if it
happens in the city it just simply takes
longer to get to the hospital
longer to get to the dock
so the bipartisan infrastructure bill we
included
27.5 billion dollars
for smaller bridges including dedicated
funding for off-system bridges
and folks look we used to be rated the
number one infrastructure had the number
one infrastructure in the world
we're now number eight
united states of america
the united states of america
and folks here in iowa
our bipartisan infrastructure law is
delivering 93 million dollars for those
bridges just this year
93 million
[Applause]
at least 14 million for off system
bridges this year
look this investment is going to help
connect entire towns and regions and new
opportunities
we've gone from waiting for
infrastructure week
now you've got infrastructure
infrastructure a decade
10 years
10 years
and we owe it to you soon
look it's going to help workers get jobs
good paying jobs products get to market
reduce costs for families
with this investment we're sending the
message
to america's small communities and the
people who call your call you home
this home
you matter
you matter we see you
not a joke
and we're building back with you
we're making sure
you're not left out or left behind
we're also investing in universal
affordable high-speed internet
i was surprised at this number i have to
tell you 16
of iowa households don't have an
internet subscription
in some places there's no high-speed
internet infrastructure at all
zero in this state
and the law will make high-speed
internet affordable available everywhere
in iowa
and think of what that will make
possible
from telemedicine to precision
agriculture to small businesses that
want to be able to sell in bigger
markets
in the 21st century in america
no parent ever should have to pull into
mcdonald's or a fast food chain to
literally hook up to the internet in
their car so the kid could do their
homework over on the line online
think about it
the united states of america
we're the guys that came up with all
this stuff
our infrastructure law invests in clean
water and waste water systems including
a major investment in the newer lewis
and clark rural water system to bring
clean reliable drinking water to more
than 350 000 people in south dakota to
minnesota to northwest iowa it matters
it matters of the health and matters of
convenience and matters across the board
we're investing in ports and waterways
including over 700 million dollars
for lock and dam project 25 on the
mississippi you say what does that have
to do with me has a lot to do with
yellow
because nearly every bushel of soybean
and corn that is transported on that
river from illinois iowa minnesota
missouri wisconsin goes through these
locks
and they were built in 1930
1930s
barges often need to be split into
smaller groups to make it through
taking hours and sometimes greater
delays with new modern locks we're gonna
help farmers get their products to
market faster more efficiently lower
cost and keep american hackers are
globally competitive
folks the list goes on i'm starting to
bore myself here but this is important
stuff
i think i think
in fact
members of my administration and i will
be visiting rural america
in over 25 states over the next three
weeks to talk about
how we can do even more through great
jobs and opportunity
to make sure that the investments we're
making reach rural communities
buy from rural businesses create jobs
here at home
giving your young people the opportunity
to make a living and raise a family in a
place where they were raised where they
want to stay
[Applause]
i won't ask the people i know no woman
is over 50 years of age here but the men
are over 50.
how many times
have you had a son or daughter niece or
nephew say i don't want to move but i
have to there's no job here
i don't have a chance here
we're changing that
let me close with this
when i was running for office i heard it
a thousand times
we're going to build an economy around
you
the communities who feed and fuel our
nation but we are
we are
we're going to deal in people in places
that have been left out and left behind
for a long time
we're making progress
over the course of my presidency
our recovery has now created 7.9 million
jobs in almost 17 months 14 months
[Applause]
more jobs created over the first 14
months of any president in american
history
and by 2021
our economy created more jobs in rural
america
than occurred in the last 15 years
so i'm more optimistic about america
today than i've been in my whole life
i uh my doc i had a i had an aneurysm
when i was much younger
and i was put in the hospital as a
senator
and he started explaining to me what an
aneurysm was i said i don't need to know
he said
i'm just gonna just take top your head
off and do something with it
and uh i said no you do your job i'll do
mine i'll be the patient
and after it was all over he said you
know your problem is senator the senator
i said no he said you're a congenital
optimist
and i am because i'm an american
that's why i'm optimistic because i see
a future that's within our grasp no
hyperbole
we're the only nation on earth
this is not true chauvinism this is
truth we're the only nation on earth if
you think about it
that's come out of every major crisis
stronger than when we went in
we just didn't go back to where we were
we came out stronger
stronger literally every major crisis
if we faced we turned into an
opportunity
that's exactly what we're going to do
today
with all of you
i i can't thank you enough for your
all the work you put in
all the faith you have in your state
your community your country
and
i just want to say god bless you all and
every time i walk out of my grandpa
finnegan's house up in scranton which
died when coal died it's coming back
every time
you walk out the door and you know
joey keep the faith
and then one of my my grandmother or my
aunt would yell no joey spread it let's
go spread the faith thank you very much
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
more
[Music]
huh
[Music]
down
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
bye
[Music]
now
[Music]
you